servus leute was geht erst am titel
gesehen und es ist kein krieg bei tages
gekommen an dem ich nach zwei hat er
absolut geiler zusammen wir waren mit
dem schlussstrich ziehen
warum das so ist erklärt im laufe des
videos und damit dass ein bisschen
besten steht hier ist meine kleine
geschichte ich habe ungefähr acht jahren
glaube ich war ich damals zum ersten mal
die handykamera für meine mutter
entdeckt habt ihr aber geschnappt und
hat durch die gegend gefilmt weil es
mich einfach damals schon so fasziniert
hat die realität irgendwie einfach zu
kalt das wasser ist nun irgendwie auch
schon hängen und schenkt ihr könnt ihr
euch das gar nicht vorstellen weil ihr
wachsen heute mit handykameras auch aber
für mich war das echt krank und
irgendwann dann eigentlich zehn jahre
waren wir nicht so zum ersten mal einen
pc gelassen worden und hat dann auch
schon mit paid experimentiere oder
irgendwelchen sachen bearbeitet bis
training mit zwölf jahren after effects
entdeckt hat effekt ganz kurz das
programm mit dem man die ganzen effekte
machen kann mit dem man flammen machen
kann und green screen und explosionen
und alles möglich ihr wisst was ich
meine
das hat mich damals schon so fasziniert
dass man damit zum beispiel dass ich
damit zum beispiel einfach ein bild auf
irgendeiner oberfläche treppen konnte
also quasi ein probiert ob irgendwo dran
kleben kann ohne dass ich das wirklich
mag sondern hat einfach nur mit das wort
hört mit 15 jahren habe ich dann meine
erste richtige kamera bekommen das war
die kerne und 600d damals die rolle der
philips in dessen zimmer ich gerade
übrigens auch hin und drehe
das war der erste kamera und damit haben
sozusagen mit dem banner kumpel von
zuerst der youtube sketche gedreht so
bisher in richtung city war auch
ziemlich inspiriert von die bahn halb da
gerade im halbfinal egal da habe ich
noch nicht mal dran gedacht irgendwie
youtube mal büro fit zu machen
es war so weit außerhalb meiner realität
dass ich nicht mal gewagt war überhaupt
das kannst du denken dass es sein könnte
irgendwann einfach 16 habe ich
angefangen kraftsport zumachen und hab
dann auf youtube tutorials gesucht zu
irgendwelchen übungen oder zur ernährung
damit man das alles richtig angeht und
hab da und starrt ist ein youtube
bedachten typ interessiert sich also für
sich selbst zu entwickeln sich selbst zu
verbesseren dem schlagen wir nochmal
persönlichkeitsentwicklung des videos
vor also quasi was kommunikation angehe
was auch natürlich sport angeht aber was
auch gemeint habe generell glaubenssätze
und gedanken angeht und auch
einstellungen wie man halt vielleicht
bisschen lockerer wäre und positive und
alles mögliche was ich in diesem video
hat immer wieder gefunden hat waren hat
menschen die irgendetwas in ihrem leben
haben wo sie halt kommt ihre andy reid
indes sehen können und eine leidenschaft
oder hat einen traum hat irgendein
bereich dem sie ihr leben widmen kann
und halten ihr herzblut und als ihr
energie und zeit und liebe schenken
können und da hat sie mir also was
brauche ich auch aber das problem war
ist es halt einfach nicht leicht zu
finden und sie kennen das vielleicht ihr
so überlegt und jetzt vielleicht okay
was könnte ich mal arbeiten was will ich
arbeite nach der schule und das gesamte
ultra schwer erkenntnis bringt alle und
ich weiß nicht genau wie das passiert
ist aber irgendwann plötzlich war sein
motto klar dass das wonach ich gesucht
habe einfach die effekte sind das ist
das filmen ist die kamera und das video
machen ab dem zeitpunkt kam dann so zum
ersten mal der wunsch stehen die
selbstständig musikvideos bei youtube an
youtube habe ich noch nicht mal wirklich
ich glaube dass ich dachte nicht dass
das ding gibt überhaupt realistisch ist
sowas zu erhalten und so kam es dann
dass ich mit diesen traum und diesem
willen mich weiterzuentwickeln und zu
verbessern und 2 1 gebieten ziehen wir
das film angeht sondern auch fast
gesundheitssport intellektuelle freiheit
angeht das ging so weit dass ich dann
irgendwann obwohl das eigentlich
geplante castor abschließe und man
allgemein das abitur nach das sagt
sowohl ich also meine eltern und alle
möglichen freunde auch ich habe danach
den abgeschossenen 12 in kassel also ich
habe ein fachabitur ich hatte einfach
schluss dass ich danach gesagt okay du
kannst du dich klasse die werte jetzt
hin und verfolgt komplett dieses eine
ziel längst durchschaut habe ich mich
dann ohne irgendwelche perspektive ein
musikvideo eingesetzt welches wir für
musik video wettbewerb angemeldet haben
und das ist musik video da habe ich drei
monate lang sieben tage die woche jede
sekunde meines lebens da ein gestrecktes
möglichst heftig zu machen das findet
ihr unter aller betriebe
von lux und irgendwann kann mir die für
heute in dem ich mit diesem musikvideo
bei travel dank ist uns schon gut zu
behörden und ich habe mich gar nicht
mehr viel gedacht danach also dachte
nicht unbedingt glaube ich dass da ist
und dann eben halt wirklich drauf der
kommende gegner fremd person und diese
von ihrer bank nummer und ich wusste
nicht okay was bilder jetzt und dann hat
sich herausgestellt dass das gymi von
der firma und die sich mit mir
tatsächlich in köln treffen wollten das
war für mich echt zu früh über hilft
dann nicht beschreiben was da in mir
vorging ich bin direkt vor meinem zimmer
herunter gerannt und hat mal geld
bescheinigten der das schon auf tool von
aber der diako daran die ganzen standen
wie groß dieses youtube ist auf jeden
fall lacht philipp anrufen mit dem
zusammen diese traum entstanden ist der
kinder leider nicht kann und dann bin
ich einfach nach draußen gerannt da war
es geradezu jugendlich weiß wieso ich
draußen bin ich aber genau da bin ich
nach köln habe mich mit ihm getroffen
ich war schockiert weil ich nicht wusste
wie ich mich verhalten soll also dachten
die wahrscheinlich dass sich der ultra
spastiken das hat dann natürlich nicht
glaubt ihr ist denn die hatten zu dem
zeitpunkt für marius gefunden und er
macht auch echten kein shop aber mich
hat es halt ultra mitgenommen also ich
100 vorstellen was das für ein gefühl
gewinnst du stand war und wieder nicht
da da natürlich war auf jeden fall ich
mich dann mit diesen geilen wege auch
bei filmproduktionen geborgen wurden
praktikum ab heute und da habe ich dann
eine angenommen die in berlin war
ich will gar nicht weiter darauf
eingehen
das video ist eine heavy zeit für mich
ich habe das bip das ist überhaupt nicht
das was ich machen will
du hast mir dachte okay schon in bälde e
mail gelesen anscheinend lesen ich habe
ja tatsächlich ihre e-mails die da auch
öffentlich zugänglich sind im internet
und da habe ich mich einfach noch ein
paar andere mit jugendlich cool fand und
da hat sich dann irgendwann tatsächlich
regel jetzt mit dem ich mich dann auch
getroffen habe wir haben uns recht gut
verstanden als ich war richtig
überrascht wie cool ja nicht drauf des
videos ist halt noch ein bisschen agro
und so weiter und so fort
aber bei der mega net haben uns sehr gut
verstanden so dass wir dann halt weil
natürlich fand auch im arbeitskreis noch
okay lass es machen da ich vor zwei
jahren angefangen zu schneiden und vom
alltag jahren bin ich hier eingezogen
und seid ihr könnt ihr mich auch auf
seinen videos und der rest ist
geschichte die man so schön sagt so und
jetzt wisst ihr dass mir die welt in
dickem unter ständige wachstum eine
ständige über sich selbst hinauswachsen
für mich sehr wichtig ist und da bin ich
zu dem entschluss gekommen dass es
langsam an der zeit ist den nächsten
schritt zu wagen das ist ein zu meiner
zeit ist mir mehr zeit zu nehmen für
sport für meditation für auch meine
eigenen youtube videos so habe ich das
auf wenige sagt oder vielleicht doch
jetzt gleich okay das ist dann mega der
streit geworden
da gab es über den bv dessen welches
auch bei dem zwischen alten oder ihr
habt ihr jetzt vielleicht gedacht
johanna direkten scheiß krank gemacht
und deswegen an den riemen jetzt
wirklich mal herausgebracht
das ist es nicht gehe jetzt auch
komplett verstanden dass ich da jetzt
ein schritt gehen dass die zeitverträge
war das ist echt war hammergeil jahre
waren die ich dabei ich war und ich gebe
ich alles zu bringen habe auch das hier
diesen kompletten kanal ich hinten
die möglichkeit dass ich hier
kontrolliert die möglichkeit dass sie
direkt fast direkt nachdem ich kann sie
die schule abgebrochen habe herr
verlieren konnte einfach nur das zu
machen worauf boca wird mit 100 prozent
quasi in die richtung
wir entwickeln das alles nicht machen
können da hätte ich wahrscheinlich
irgendwo nebenjob mehr machen müssen
oder dem ich schon mal aus nicht
gebildet stunden in der woche nicht das
machen hätte können was ich wollte und
dann nur nebenbei
am abend werde ich schon mal traf ich
bin von der arbeit das befolgen können
was ich eigentlich glaube so konnte ich
dort prozent direkt das machen was ich
eigentlich wollte was hat pult rede
heftige glückspilz aber nichtsdestotrotz
ist es jetzt an der zeit das für
jemanden zu schaffen jemand neue derweil
rief zu einer leidenschaft reinstetten
kann und sich denken kann uns einen
traum gegeben hat und für mich ist sehen
wir das hat jetzt das neue kapital zu
kommen
nach den letzten zwei jahren schon echt
kräftigsten überhaupt waren jetzt quasi
das neue kapitel anzufahren und langsam
mal zu den vielleicht auch eigene
besteht das eigene youtube den komplett
in den fokus nehmen nebenbei natürlich
haben wir zeit zu nehmen für mich sagen
ein bisschen mal wieder sachen zu machen
die ich jetzt leider nicht machen konnte
nicht mal wegen baby ich hätte daneben
regelt arbeit trotzdem noch genug zeit
gehabt aber das wollen natürlich lewis
arbeitet und dann auch meinen youtube
befolgen und dafür das darf man you tube
drückte dann habe ich natürlich sehr
sehr viele samt vernachlässigt wie zum
beispiel über die gesundheit freunde
familie kösters und bin ich sagen möchte
ich mir wieder mehr zeit nehmen aber
natürlich auch für youtube und jetzt die
frage vielleicht geht es weiter ich kann
natürlich nicht komplett aufhören mit
dem was du tun musst also privat werde
ich mich halten wir die treffen und ich
war das nicht auch beruflich noch
projekte starten mal musikvideo oder
irgendein zusatz kamera
der rauch wurde alles mögliche generell
gibt es erst in zwei monaten so langsam
der übergang stadt in der sich heute auf
morgen auf für ewig die videos schneiden
genau was jetzt eben mit diesem kanal
passieren wird ist dass ich auf jeden
fall zwei mal die woche im jahr das
video gucken will das soll das mit
büchern zu tun zu haben
das sollte natürlich auch was mit gaming
zu tun zu haben aber nicht wohin willst
seiner spiele sondern muss zum beispiel
jetzt ein video gibt wo ich halt bischof
ex ihnen vorteile oder ford hat in sri
lanka oder auch in minecraft oder halt
auch gegen das ohne computerspiele
irgendwas galt es muss auch nicht immer
defektes an aber ich habe doch gerade
sagen zu kreieren die halt einfach da wo
sie heute denken anabolika hälfte muss
natürlich nicht immer die schiene sein
ich werde auch mal einen blog machen
aber er ist ungefährlich hier nicht und
es gehen soll geld ausgeben aber nicht
unbedingt auf diesem kanal sondern auch
meint rich kanal wo ich regelmässig
leistet wie man direkt in der
beschreibung aus auch ins land geht
natürlich weiter da habe ich jetzt schon
die letzte zeit hält sich regelmäßig
jeden zweiten tagung gibt er einblick
die post könnte ja auch gemacht hätten
wenn ihr übrigens bock habt die chance
die sie als baby auftritt zu nutzen dann
können wir auch mal sein video abchecken
und dann könnt ihr euch dafür werden
wenn ihr euch wenn ihr lust habt dann
könnt ihr das mal ich habe jetzt auf
jeden fall lothar bock auch wenn es echt
ein bisschen sentimental das thema ist
weil sie jetzt nicht komplett abschied
nehmen weil sie schon zum bisher
ich hatte schon ein letzter halt ein
bisschen in ostalgie keks weiß war ein
echt nur noch teilzeit die karten bei
den musikvideos diese
auch generell im büro im neuen büro oder
jetzt rufen natürlich die ganze zeit die
wir daten
das war schon recht heftig und dazu den
zu blicken ist schon ein bisschen so die
melancholie schiene aber nächstes jahr
wie jetzt im bock drauf diesen neuen
abschnitt da anzugehen europa sehe mich
komplett darauf zu konzentrieren
diesen kanal nach vorn zu bringen und
meine kreativität meine träume zum
ausdruck zu bringen und läutet
vielleicht ein paar von euch zu
inspirieren irgendwas gerade zu machen
aber auch selbst inspiriert zu werden
und jetzt ein bisschen einfach bekommen
wie ich hierhergekommen bin so wir
hatten ein bisschen zu und lesereise
mitgekriegt und wenn ihr bock habt mich
auf den rest der reise sowie galt ja wo
ist und überall hingehen kann ja ein
paar große töne gespuckt und leute das
wird echt geil
antwort ich weiß noch nicht mal selber
wie geil ist wieder bitterkalt noch mal
vielen dank an die größte ehre überhaupt
ist es nicht selbstverständlich dass er
seine eigene karte also ordentlich
aufgehängt und mit der öffentlichkeit
teilt die meisten youtuber haben katar
eigentlich fast alle großen youtube
haben katze aber die wenigsten geben zu
und noch weniger öffentlichen die kasse
dann auch noch ja vielen unternehmen
nicht die mögliche nicht jetzt ohne ihn
hätte ich diese unfassbar seltene
möglichkeit nicht und ich weiß die
wirklichkeit zu schätzen weil ich weiß
wie viele leute sich so was wünschen
würden und wie wenige ist dann natürlich
auch letztendlich ausleben können auch
wenn ich dabei natürlich nicht vergessen
wie viel arbeit es trotzdem für meine
seite war dazu kommen dennoch guter
läufer und ein riesen glück dazu nehmen
das wäre ok maria bock habt mich weiter
zu verfolgen und was treibt die jungen
er zu den proben und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder was gut tut
[Musik]